[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ZELDA LA GRANGE:
Thank you, Natalie.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Thank you very much,
Rob, also, for having us.
It's an honor to be in London,
although this weather gets
to me every time I visit London.
Thanks, Natalie.
NATALIE MAYHEW:
Thank you for coming.
So how did you
then become to work
for him within his company?
And how did your family take
it, I suppose, the change?
ZELDA LA GRANGE: In
1994, Mr. Mandela
became the first democratically
elected president in April of--
May 1994.
And in October of that
year, I applied for a job
in his extended office.
He had a few ministers
in his office.
And one of the ministers,
it was good for a minister
without portfolio.
So I looked at the ad.
And I was only
driven by the fact
that I needed a job
closer to my parents' home
because I was still living with
them at the age of 23, which
no child should do
at the age of 23.
I was living with
my parents, and I
needed a job closer to home.
So that was the one thing that
was attractive about the job
that the Union Buildings in
which the president's head
office is situated was
close to my parents' home.
And secondly, the job
was also advertised
that you would do six months
duty in Pretoria, which
is the administrative capital.
It's about 20 miles, I
think, from Johannesburg.
I'm not sure about
miles and kilometers,
but about 20 miles
from Johannesburg.
And then you could
spend six months--
the rest of the six
months of the year,
you could spend in Cape Town.
Now, you all know, if
you know South Africa,
everyone knows about Cape Town.
And even as a young
South African,
we all just want
to go to Cape Town.
So the job was advertised
as part of a sessional duty
office, so you could spend six
months of the year in Pretoria,
and then when Parliament
is in session in Cape Town,
you would spend the six
months in Cape Town.
Those two things
were the only things
that I was interested
in when I applied
for the job in the
ministry without portfolio.
I thought to myself,
well, because there's
no portfolio attached
to this minister,
the job couldn't
be too complicated.
I thought to myself,
this minister
doesn't even have a job because
he doesn't have a portfolio.
So I thought to myself,
apply for the job
and see how it goes.
And of course, never
thinking that I would end up
in Mr. Mandela's office.
So I was invited for an
interview in the head
office of the presidency.
And during the
interview, I was still
conversing with the HR people.
And the door flung open,
and this very flamboyant,
beautifully dressed
black lady entered.
Her name was Mary.
And she was the president's--
President Mandela's private
secretary at the time.
Now, if you don't believe
in fate or destiny,
then this story will make you
believe in fate and destiny.
I sat in that office
when Mary entered.
And she really just physically
burst into the office
without announcement
and interrupting us.
And she just said,
I need an assistant,
and I need it right now.
And I didn't care
what color she is.
And I thought to
myself, I'm your person.
You need someone?
I need a job, yeah.
You know, the two of
us, it's meant to be.
And she left.
We never got introduced.
And I was never
told who she was.
And after the interview, they
called me, and they said,
would you be interested in
a job in President Mandela's
private office?
And I thought to
myself, private,
it sounds dangerous, actually.
I thought, well, I hope I never
expected to go to his house.
Because now, remember, I'm still
very afraid of this person.
With the same conservative
mindset, I thought,
if I work in a bigger office,
I could just disappear.
So a private office, you
know, didn't sound right.
And so I said, is this job in
the Union Buildings in the head
office, because I
was trying to avoid
to go to a private office.
They said, yes, yes, it's
in the Union Buildings.
I said, and would
I be able to do
sessional duties, six months
Pretoria, six months Cape Town.
They said, yes.
I said, I'm sold--
never asking questions about
how big is this private office,
you know, who would
I be working for,
would I ever have to
meet the president.
Never asking those questions.
It was just the logistics
that made sense to me
and that was attractive to me.
And so I said yes.
And of course, then I realized--
the first day, I started my
job in the Union Buildings.
I thought at first that
I made a big mistake.
I walked into this
very stately office.
It's like 10 Downing Street.
And you walk into his
office, and the doors
open by motion detector.
And it's very stately
inside and very formal.
And you can hardly hear a pin
drop, and all this grandeur
and beautiful carpets
and everything.
And then I met
one or two people,
and I thought, well,
where is the rest?
Where's the other 200 people
I'm expecting to find here?
And they said, no,
no, no, we are only
five people in the
president's private office.
So for the first few
weeks in my job there,
whenever I heard the
president arriving,
I would just lock
my door quickly,
my office door, the
door to my office,
and hide, because I
thought, we can never meet.
I just can't meet this person.
And you know, he's
the president now.
And I also kind of feel
ashamed for Apartheid.
And I'm understanding a
little bit more, of course,
now of the environment.
But I thought, it's just not
proper that we ever meet.
So I would really hide
for the first few weeks.
NATALIE MAYHEW: It's
astonishing to go from that
to where you ended up.
So the title of this book is
"Good Morning, Mr. Mandela."
But that came from a
watershed moment, didn't it?
So I know because
I've read the book.
But how did that happen?
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Yeah, so
two weeks into the job,
I walked into Mary's
office because, of course,
I was now employed by her.
I walked into her
office to deliver
a pile of books or something.
And suddenly, this group of
people, a crowd of people
exited her office, all men, all
of them dressed in dark suits.
They're wearing
sunglasses indoors.
They have hearing aids, and
they have all this technology,
speaking to their watches.
And you're realizing, oh,
this is like bodyguards.
These are definitely the
stereotype bodyguards.
And immediately, you
realize, well, these people
are all armed so you need to
behave in a different way now.
Don't make sudden movements.
And then things started
happening in slow motion for me
because this moment
was so important.
And from this crowd
of people emerged
President Mandela, the
first democratically
elected black president
of South Africa.
And the first
thing, of course, I
say to him was, good
morning, Mr. Mandela.
And he extended his hand to me.
And I thought, well, what
am I supposed to do now.
And now, you must remember,
I'm 23 years of age.
I'm young.
I'm naive.
I'm stupid.
I am vulnerable, extremely
vulnerable still.
And he's extending
his hand to me.
And I thought-- it was like
moments that I thought, well,
should I run away.
Can I turn around and
run down this corridor?
And then I realized, well,
these people all armed.
They're going to shoot
you on this carpet.
[LAUGHTER]
There's going to be
blood everywhere.
Don't run.
You can't run.
And then the first
thing you notice
when you meet Nelson
Mandela for the first time
was this incredible
kindness in his eyes,
the sincerity of his smile,
this infectious smile of his.
And he looked at me, still
waiting for me to do something.
And I took his hand.
And throughout the
conversation, he
held my hand into a firm
grip, just holding onto it.
And then there was a pause.
He was saying something,
and there was a pause.
And I realized, well, he
just asked me something.
But I have no idea
what he just asked.
And I had to ask him
to repeat himself.
So I said, excuse
me, Mr. President.
So when he repeated
himself, I realized
he was speaking to me in
Afrikaans, my home language
and the language of the
white people, the language
of the oppressor
in South Africa.
And I heard him
say over the years
that when you speak to a
man, it goes to his head,
but when you speak to
a man in his language,
it goes to his heart.
That's what he did that day.
By holding onto my hand and
speaking to me in Afrikaans,
he destroyed my
defenses immediately,
and he opened me up to
the rest of my life.
That was the watershed
moment for me
because I then found this
person in front of me.
We stood there for
about seven minutes.
Well, it felt like two years.
But he asked about
my upbringing.
Luckily, he didn't
ask what I voted.
OK?
Because I think that was
going to be the last--
no, not really.
He asked about my family.
He asked about my
upbringing, about my parents,
everything, these very
unimportant things, really.
And I felt respected for
that moment, standing there.
And I felt undeserving.
Because of course, then, I knew
of the history of South Africa,
what happened in my country.
And immediately, you
feel responsible,
because the person you
find in front of you
is completely the opposite
of what you were taught
to believe about this man.
He's friendly.
He's kind.
He's extremely caring
in just his personality.
So you know what women do best
in a situation like that then?
We start crying as well.
Still holding his
hand, now, that tears
are rolling down my face.
And I try and answer
whatever he was asking.
And he saw I was crying.
And then he put his other
hand on my shoulder.
And he said, no, no, no, relax,
you are overreacting now.
Of course, he realized that I
felt responsible immediately,
and that I felt
sorry, and that I--
I was just overcome
with emotion.
And that moment really
changed my entire life.
Because I walked away from that
meeting wanting to know more,
what happened in my country.
Why these things that I
was told in the media,
in the church, my parents--
I had to question
my own upbringing
and have very difficult
conversations with people,
asking, why didn't you tell me.
Why did you only present
one side of history to us?
And yeah, it was all
started by just that one
moment with Mr. Mandela.
NATALIE MAYHEW: Do you
have any questions?
I'll keep going.
I have loads.
AUDIENCE: I'm short, so
I might just take time.
Hi.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that this sort of role, job
can kind of consume a life, and
their life becomes your life.
Prior to you getting the first
role, what was your dream job?
Or where did you think
it was going to be?
And do you ever
regret not pursuing
that over where you are now?
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank you, yes.
At the age of 23, I
really just wanted
a day job, something just
to earn a little money
to buy my makeup.
And I had no real
ambition at that point.
My father was a businessman.
And he was a logistics manager
at the South African Breweries.
And he had a very, very
effective personal assistant.
And she really embraced me.
And I wanted to be as
organized and performing
like Danny, who
was the secretary.
So that was who I
wanted to become.
I wanted to marry and have
three children, three boys,
to be specific.
But then, you
know, life happens.
Something happens along the way.
You don't recognize
these opportunities
when they come along.
And as I said to you, destiny
and fate played a role.
And this is the life
that was handed to me.
And I always say to people
that when you talk of regret,
I look at Nelson Mandela's life.
And I look at him spending
27 years in prison,
away from his family,
away from life,
sacrificing, really, his
life so that I could have
the freedom of speech,
the freedom of movement,
the freedom of
association today.
So who am I to talk
about my sacrifices
in comparing my life to his?
My sacrifices,
there was nothing.
There was really none.
I would do everything
exactly the same
if I knew what I do
now, well, 25 years ago.
And there's 7.5 billion
people on the planet now.
Right?
And I am that one person
who had this opportunity.
So how do I dare
talk about regret?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Zelda, I'm
your fellow South African
and also, I guess, Afrikaner.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Hello.
Oh, and [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I'm wearing my Madiba
t-shirt for you, as well.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Oh,
it's a fabulous t-shirt.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It was really
interesting to listen to you
talking about your upbringing.
I mean, I was born two weeks
before the Soweto riots.
So I know about indoctrination
by state and by family
and by church more
than most actually.
I was just wondering,
what is your perspective
on how racial
attitudes have changed
for white people in South
Africa towards other races,
and particularly, I
guess, Afrikaners?
Do you think we're there?
Do we have a long way to go?
And where do you see it going?
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank you.
Yeah, I always say
to people, it feels
like we haven't made
progress, but we
have made a lot of
progress in South Africa.
Look at me.
Change is possible.
And we measure things
maybe differently
now because of technology.
I think in South
Africa you will always
have-- in any society
across the world,
you will have pockets of racism.
People will just simply
refuse to change,
not for any good
reasoning, but people
who just don't want to change.
And you'll always have
that in any society.
South Africa,
specifically, I think
there's been massive,
massive progress
as far as racial
relationships are concerned.
The problem, however,
there is that I
heard someone say that
we live in the age
of smartphones
and stupid people.
So, [INAUDIBLE] people, it's the
age of instant gratification.
We don't listen to
each other anymore.
And you know, that was
one of Madiba's strongest
characteristics was his
ability to listen to people
and to listen with the intention
of really understanding
what a person is saying,
rather than listening
with the intention
of responding.
And with smartphones
and social media
these days, that's what we do.
We look at something.
And without thinking or
listening, we respond.
Because I do want most likes.
I do want to be the
most famous person.
Or I do want to shame
someone publicly.
So that's who we, as
a society, has become.
So when it comes to racial
relations in South Africa,
you have the radicals.
And I'm sure you know
who I'm talking about.
And we have the radicals on
both white and black side,
that it makes it appear that
we haven't made progress
or that we are moving backwards.
But you know what?
In all the years, I have
not found that people
on the street that's
so intolerant as you
see in politicians.
People on the street in South
Africa are not intolerant.
People in the street
want to live together.
They want to work together
to bring solutions.
So I do think we've
made great progress.
It's just that it
appears, because things
are so open and so
transparent in society
because of the internet
that it appears different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
absolutely agree with you.
And especially, when you see
the newer, younger generations,
and just when you see them
going out socializing,
and just how
comfortable they are
living in such a
multicultural society.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Totally.
Totally.
I always say to people that
everywhere in the world, if you
look at the US today as well,
you have this very intolerant
atmosphere.
And it's everywhere
in the world.
It's not just America.
It's not South Africa.
Everywhere in the world,
it's the radicals shouting
that makes us all move back into
a more conservative society.
So I'd rather be bland
than say how I really feel.
The thing is that if you are
serious about righteousness,
and equality, and the freedoms
that people like Nelson Mandela
fought for, you need
to shout louder and not
become discouraged bland
society and the person who
doesn't have an opinion
just because it's safer.
It's hard.
And I myself had to learn
through social media
the hard lessons.
But it is a powerful,
powerful tool for us.
And if you look at
Nelson Mandela's legacy,
he stood on the world stage.
And then at times, there
were maybe 50,000 people
in a stadium that he addressed.
Those days, they didn't
have smartphones.
So his opinion was confined
to the 50,000 people
in front of him.
With the internet today,
all of us in this room
is on some form of social media.
If we all have 100 people
to influence, actually,
our power is much bigger
than it was those years.
You know?
And we can reach more people.
So how do you choose to
use that responsibility?
In this age of influence,
the age of technology,
use it to build the bridges,
to promote tolerance,
to promote equality, to promote
the things that we all know
makes the world a better place.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And thank you for
your time today.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Both my
parents are Palestinian.
So I'm sure you can imagine
that this is something that's
also very close to my heart.
And I was wondering
if you could maybe
speak a little bit
about Nelson Mandela
and if he ever spoke about
forgiveness from within,
or how he could come
over the things that
happened to him personally
to work with and integrate
these people who had done
this to him and in society
as he was president.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank you, yes.
Mr. Mandela, I think about
10 years after I started
working for him, he
started this thing
of saying that he misses prison.
I would like, what?
I said, you can't say that.
That's disgusting to say
that you miss prison.
Don't repeat that.
And then he said it's not
that he missed prison,
it's that he misses
the opportunity
to think about things properly.
And he then said to me--
at another stage I
said to him, when
I started knowing him quite
well, I said, you know what?
It's very unnatural of
you not to hate, not
to have resentment, and not
to want to have revenge.
And with me alongside you,
just take that opportunity.
And I'm sure we
can overcome this.
But be angry at me
because it's not natural
that you are not angry.
You have to be angry at
white people specifically.
So I said, take it out on me.
We can sing "Kumbaya"
afterwards again.
You know?
We can make up.
But you have to get it out.
And then he would laugh at me.
And he would say to
me, there's no anger.
There's no resentment.
Because he realized that
unless he worked it himself,
he could not take
the country forward.
So unless he worked at his own
anger and his own resentment,
he couldn't influence
the people around him.
And he said, it's
much harder work
to change yourself than it
is to change other people.
So when it comes to
something like forgiveness,
when it comes to something
like reconciliation,
that made me realize
that, in prison, he
took a lot of time thinking
about these things.
What is the best way forward?
And it is really to work
at oneself much harder.
In forgiving, you have to also
reconcile with your own past.
Through my life story, I had
to come to terms with the fact
that that is who I was.
And that is why I can be
so brutally honest about,
yes, I was a racist when
I started working for him.
But I've been
through this change.
And we need to take
the time to think
of ourselves in any
situation and how
do I appear to
other people, rather
than wanting to preach
to people how to behave.
Because we all
know how difficult
it is to change behavior.
If you want to stop drinking,
stop swearing, stop smoking,
stop whatever it is,
it's difficult. Yet,
we want to tell everyone
around us how to behave.
Behavior is like fashion.
If I change my behavior,
other people will follow.
So all of that made me realize
that Mr. Mandela worked very
hard at himself to forgive.
And it's only because
he did that that we
had such a smooth
transition in South Africa
because the people
followed his example.
AUDIENCE: That's very brave
of you to work on yourself
and share this
experience with us also.
Thank you so much for that.
ZELDA LA GRANGE: Thank
you very, very much.
NATALIE MAYHEW: So
one final question.
What did you learn most from
President Nelson Mandela?
ZELDA LA GRANGE:
I think the lesson
that stands out, Natalie, is
to respect, to respect people,
irrespective of who they
are, and what they represent,
and what they appear to me
to be, without judgment.
Mr. Mandela always said that
if you question a person's
integrity without
valid reason, it
could well be a reflection
of your own integrity.
And I often think
of those things.
And I always think of the
person that approaches me now,
strip him from all those
layers, because that's
what I learned from Mr. Mandela
is strip stripping from what he
wears, what he or she wears,
from their sexual preference,
from their wealthy status,
their appearance, all of that,
their ideology, their religion,
their conviction, all of that,
politics.
Strip the person and connect
with the human being.
And that is what made him
such an effective world leader
as well is that he always
was able to connect
to the humanity of a
person above ideology.
And I think that
speaks of respect.
And if we can all
just try and do that,
recognizing the human
being behind every person
that we come across, then it
makes the world a better place.
And I bear witness to the fact
that I saw a person waking up
every morning.
Nelson Mandela, for
19 years, he decided,
purposefully, every
single morning, he
decided, if I can change, or if
I can touch one person's life
today, I can change the world.
He really believed in
that individual action.
And if you now look at
world history, he did.
So it's in our power.
It wasn't that he was
a super human being.
He was an ordinary human
being like all of us.
But he made decisions and
always choosing the right thing.
And I think that
kind of respect,
that kind of self-respect as
well, is the lesson that I
take away from my experience.
NATALIE MAYHEW:
That's fascinating.
So it's been amazing having you.
And thank you so much for coming
all the way from South Africa
to be with us today.
The book is available.
You can buy it.
It's a great read.
I definitely recommend it.
It's available on Google Play.